hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar optimizing treatment options for
her to positive and ER positive breast
cancer using models of endocrine
resistance
I am Alexis corrosive Leopards and I'll
be our moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lap birds and brought to
you by thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more about our sponsor please visit
www.thegrape.com uniike uestions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left ear
screen this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits I now present today's speaker
dr. Hilary steyr postdoctoral fellow
Georgetown University Lombardi
Comprehensive Cancer Center
dr. stires is a postdoctoral fellow
training in the tumor biology program
funded through a t32 Ruth L kerosene
National Research Service Award at
Georgetown University Lombardi
Comprehensive Cancer Center under the
mentorship of dr. Rebecca Riggins dr.
stires received her PhD from Rutgers
University and endocrinology and animal
Biosciences and has always been
interested in how steroid hormones
specifically estrogen influence breast
cancer development for our complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen dr. stires you may now begin your
presentation
you
hello and thank you for that
introduction as mentioned my name is
Hilary sires I'm a post-doctoral solid
Georgetown University's medical center
and Lombardi Comprehensive Cancer Center
thank you to give Co for inviting me to
do this presentation and thank you to
all of you for attending it first off I
wanted to give you a little bit of
background about myself I did my peed
I'm sorry I did my Bachelors of Science
in behavioral neuroscience at Lehigh
University and I followed that up with a
PhD in under chronology and animal
Biosciences at Rutgers University and
the reason I moved into my PhD and
endocrinology was because I was
interested in finding a bridge between
my neuroscience background and work in
cancer research and so I did my PhD at
Rutgers and then I followed that up and
I'm currently doing my doctoral
fellowship and tumor biology at
Georgetown University as you can see on
the right my lab is
showing there with my group my twitter
handle is up at the top one of the
things that I've really what grown a
passion about is tweeting about my
research and about breast cancer and
below the picture of my lab you can see
the group of women that I tweet with and
then some of their no men pictures but
there are men who are part of the group
a BCS M which stands for breast cancer
social media
in our lab we study breast cancer and as
you can see from this map that breast
cancer is the top cancer with an
estimated based off estimated number of
new new cases for 2018 for females and
the vast majority of countries in the
world over 2 million new diagnoses that
diagnosis are made per year will
worldwide and it is estimated that there
522 thousand deaths each year and people
don't die because they have a single
lump in their breast most people die
from metastasis so one important thing
to consider is how many people are
living with metastatic breast cancer
it's approximately 150,000 people in the
United States alone and one in three
people with early-stage breast cancer
will develop metastasis so our goal when
we study breast cancer is to stop the
cancer before it metastasizes using
different drugs as well as slow and
reduced metastasis that have occurred to
do this we subdivide breast cancer into
a few different cases the first
subdivision that we do is to look at
cancers that Express the formalin
receptor so we subdivide the cancers
into expressing the hormone receptor or
hormone receptor pod negative or those
that do not express the hormone receptor
or hormone receptor-positive when i say
the hormone receptor i'm speaking
specifically about estrogen receptor and
progesterone receptor
and in this case estrogen receptor
progesterone receptor or what we call
overexpressed or there's high levels of
the protein within these types of PS
there
when thinking about how estrogen works
in breast cancer we want to first
understand how a certain signals
normally in the cell so normally we see
testosterone which is a steroid hormone
as well as which estrogen also is the
testosterone is aromatized using an
enzyme called aroma taste into estradiol
and estradiol is an estrogen there are
three estrogens estradiol as drone and
estriol which astral is more often found
in pregnancy but estradiol is the most
common and the most potent of the
estrogen and so estradiol is found
circulating in the bodies of women who
are pre menopausal so their ovaries are
still working that's the main site of
estrogen production in premenopausal
women and ANA postmenopausal women they
would have local over motivation or
local production of estrogen through
adipose tissue that's found near their
breast or in their breast and what
happens is the estradiol is able to
enter passively diffuse into the cell
through the membrane and then it
interacts with the estrogen receptor
normally vast region receptor is bound
to heat shock proteins or HSP which help
to stabilize the receptor within the
cell and estrogen arrestor dial binds to
those estrogen receptors and sides
another pair of estrogen with estrogen
receptor forming a dimer and then this
dimer enters the setting to enter the
nucleus of the cell and is able to bind
to specific sites on the DNA called
estrogen response elements or ER es
along with other proteins including
co-activators and RNA polymerase leading
to transcription of genes and so that's
producing new genes that will ultimately
lead to growth and development of the
tissue and the genes that we that I
wanted to point out here though which
I'll bring back later are PGR
progesterone receptor so estrogen causes
production of progesterone receptor as
well as TF f1 and again this all this
whole process leads to growth and
development to cell division of the cell
what we use for therapy for estrogen
receptor-positive breast cancer are to
try to target some of these processes to
reduce estrogen signaling the first
place is to use an aromatase inhibitor
and there's three examples on the right
there which completely blocks that
aromatization and testosterone into
estrogen so that there's less estrogen
presence followed Xserve Silvestre or i
CI 182 two seven eight zero or in the
presentation later i'll be calling it i
see i alone without the numbers is a
selective estrogen receptor the creator
and what that means is that if enters a
cell and is able to actually degree the
estrogen receptor so it's no longer
present tamoxifen is a selective
estrogen intercept their modulator and
what it does is bind in place of of
estrogen on the estrogen receptor
preventing the estrogen receptor from
signaling through the cell
these therapies are largely successful
and have saved many lives however we
have some problems with under kathira C
the first is poor Sheeran and this
article that came out in October of this
year demonstrates that patients were
premenopausal with early-stage breast
cancer approximately 1/5 of the patients
are not adequately adherence their
endocrine therapy because often these
therapies are used for 5 to 10 years
another thing that happens with under
canopy or these therapies for estrogen
receptor use those interchangeably under
under condition receptor therapy if the
process called Enders and resistance so
what is Enderson resistance if a patient
is diagnosed as as you didn't receptor
positive breast cancer that patient will
and the patient needs surgery they'll
often undergo something on the new
adjuvant chemo new additive therapy so
in that case the patient is given one of
these under synthetic and then we
monitor before so that before surgery we
can see whether the tumor has responded
or not responded to the therapy one type
of Enderson resistance is called de novo
resistance where the patient the
patient's tumor does not respond and
other cases in more often which is more
often the case the patient does respond
however what happens for 10 the 10 years
following is that in some cases the
patient remains disease-free and about
50% of patients they experience
understand resistance and will have what
we call relapse so in that case the
tumor may come back or the patient may
become metastatic at that point
you
subtypes are subdivided into the hormone
receptor positive or negative but we
further subdivide them looking at her -
so her - is another type of receptor
that's found on the cell and in breast
cancer it can be amplified so that means
that there are additional copies of the
DNA of this protein within the DNA
versus just having it over expression of
the protein and when we look at her -
signaling her - is what we call a
tyrosine kinase receptor so the receptor
actually fits within the membrane of the
cell allowing for the receptor to
interact with different proteins or
growth factors that are on the outside
of the cell
in the case of her - it actually doesn't
bind to any specific proteins but the
other members of the her family which
include EGF are or her one cursory and
her four actually interact directly with
some of these growth factors and then
what happens next is that the - - of the
her families will die memorize together
dimerization is just the process where
the two proteins come together and binds
to one another and then this binding
allows for a signaling a signal to be
sent in the form of the phosphorylation
so these phosphorylations occur both at
at the tyrosine kinase receptor or the
herb acceptor itself and then also
downstream - other proteins that are
involved in growth pathways
you
um in this case leading to proliferation
motility invasiveness and other aspects
that lead to continued basically
continued growth and continuation of the
tumour
so therapies for her2 positive breast
cancer are shown on this slide and we
can see that Herceptin and pajetta are
both antibody antibodies that block
either in the case of Herceptin or cast
these mad blocks the phosphorylation
that occurs within the receptors
themselves or in the case of projeto for
cheese mobs the dimerization that occurs
between her two and her three
additionally there's lapatinib which is
a small molecule inhibitor which
actually can enter the cell and block
both her one and her two and finally we
have head sila or TDM one which is the T
and TDM one stands for testers mavar
Herceptin so that's the antibody and the
antibody is actually conjugated to DM 1
which is the chemo therapeutic agent
what happens here is the T on the TDM
one instead of acting as a blocker acts
as something that helps the chemotherapy
to find the cells that have her two
implication and so the TDM one binds to
the her2 and then it's internalized and
the DM one is then released causing the
cell to die
and so if we go back to look at these
breast cancer subtypes we can see that
the vast majority of breast cancers are
Hertz
HR positive the hormone
receptor-positive and that about 5% are
her to positive and hormone receptor
negative however hormone receptor
negative however we have about 10% of
all cases that we call triple positive
and triple positive just means that
they're Express the tumors Express both
/ 2 and ER and/or PR and so we're not
really sure how these patients should be
treated or how their tumors should be
treated as we have the two separate
casts classes the her2 positive
treatments work well for her T positive
and the HR positive we have those drugs
that work effectively so what do we do
with these patients that are in between
so the therapy guidelines we use ASCO
which is the american society for
clinical oncologists as has guidelines
that they release for clinicians to use
to determine how to treat patients with
these types of cancer and overall if the
tumor is her2 positive it suggested that
the the clinicians use her to targeted
therapies however these are this is the
language that's included within and the
guidelines for both her2 and here
positive and as you can see for her to
selected patients should also have
undergone therapy or under Cantera P
alone and for y positive metastatic
patients that also have her - they can
have her two targeted therapy plus an
aromatase inhibitor and that's for those
who are not chemotherapy agents
earth-sized chemotherapy Canada's so
it's confusing because the language kind
of doesn't really give us a direct
answer but what is a clinical trial show
us
so if we look at clinical trials either
for her - amplified cancer independent
of whether they had an ER status so
these inclusion criteria for these
studies was to show to say that the
patients had her two amplified cancer
and then they were able to analyze the
results post talk to look back and see
how the patients responded whether there
was whether they had ear they were TR
positive or not so this is looking at
pathological complete response and you
can see that the patients who are ear
positive do not have as high of a
pathological complete response as those
who are ear negative
overall in her two therapies alone when
the patient is her2 positive in here and
negative they have better pathological
complete response than those who also
have er positive disease so what about
studies that include concurrent underpin
therapy this is a certain these studies
are newer and they show that there seems
to be an added benefit when you include
endocrine therapy with a heard -
targeted therapy
so overall adding under consider being
her2 positive err positive breast cancer
patients improves their response and
these studies looked at how her to
treatment influenced pathological
complete response but what about the
patients that were treated with er
targeted therapies so kind of a flip
side so we see that in studies where
they look specifically at her - and then
looked afterwards that your positive
versus negative your positive did not
fare as well what about us your positive
Pugh shed and you're treated with your
your positive or SAR ear targeting
therapies what happens there so this is
looking at the results from the soft in
the text trials so these trials compared
in premenopausal women
aromatisse inhibition with ovarian
suppression versus tamoxifen with
ovarian suppression and so soft stands
for suppression of ovarian function
trial and text is tamoxifen and
hexamethylene trial so again comparing
aroma taste inhibition and tamoxifen in
patients who are pre menopausal
and that's why the ovarian suppression
is included because it helps to reduce
the amount of estrogen that's present in
this case they've ended again this
postdoc analysis where they split up
looking at her to positive versus her to
negative and what you can see is that
those patients that were her2 negative
or started keep saying her2 negative
what I mean is that they do not have an
amplification so there's no her2
amplification that aroma Roma tooth
inhibition was ovarian suppression those
patients fare better than those with
tamoxifen in a room sorry entered
ovarian suppression compared to the her2
positive patients where they fare better
with tamoxifen versus an aromatase
inhibitor suggesting that premenopausal
breast cancer responds different
differently to adjuvant therapy and
therefore estrogen receptor itself may
function differently when her to was
also present
so I've demonstrated some clinical
evidence that patients who are double or
triple positive that have her2
amplification and your your positivity
have a different biology that's
occurring compared to those that are her
too alone or assured receptor-positive
alone so the clinical evidence suggests
that the presence of estrogen receptor
affects the response to her two targeted
therapy in these double positive
patients and that's us often text child
for those clinical trials suggest that
surgeon receptor biology is distinct in
her2 positive versus her to not
amplified disease so what about the
preclinical result so a lot of research
has been done looking specifically at
her to amplifies or your positive focus
in cell culture models and in animal
models but there is not as much research
that's been done looking at her to
positive and near positive disease one
important thing to note is that her -
and number two and estrogen receptor
pathways overlap so as you can see from
here there are non genomic responses of
estrogen Northup error which I didn't
talk about earlier but they do exist and
they can - judging receptor with
estrogen present is able to interact
with her - or EGFR additionally those
downstream proteins of EGFR and her -
can interact with enter the nucleus and
interact with the nuclear genomic Ihram
mediated response as well an interesting
phenomenon is that these pathways can
switch dependence when one is inhibited
and so I'll give you some examples of
that so her2 positive her2 positive cell
line the you ACC 8-12 our three positive
or negative and progesterone receptor
negative and so as you can see if you
look at tumor cell growth in black we
see that vehicle vehicles just the what
we use as our control but there's no
effective IC i or full veteran on these
cells as to be expected there's no
estrogen earth after that's present as
is evidenced by the right side of this
on this western blot and for any other
non scientist what a western blot is it
just tells us about what protein levels
are present and so you can look at
Ritz's ER that's looking at estrogen
receptor and there's no band because
that tells us that there's no estrogen
receptor present versus if you look
above that new CT or - which is total
her - that there is a dark band and we
can use those bands to determine how
much how much protein is present in the
cells and so if we in this case this
group made cells that were resistant to
a patented by increasing the doses of
lapatinib over time and you can see that
now the cells will now that the cells
are resistant to a patented they respond
to IC i and decrease their growth and
even have a little bit
it looks like there might be some deaths
that's occurring as well and and
additionally they have now started to
express estrogen receptors so if you
look at that v column under er that
there's now a band they're telling us
that after dermis after has been turned
on and as expected I see I is an
estrogen receptor to creator so we see a
loss of estrogen receptor in response to
I see I treatment what about your
positive cell line so the flip of that
we see her too when you when you block
her to signaling over time using a
patented that now ER is turned on what
about if we block here over a long time
what happens there and in this case the
this group used the mcf-7 cell line
which is near positive PR positive her2
not amplified cell line that had a
stable over a stable expression of
aromatisse
so I mentioned earlier that the fat is
usually where the aromatisse is found to
confer testosterone and estradiol and
part of that is because epithelial cells
tend to not express aromatisse and mcf7
cells do not express aromatisse so they
did here is they cause the cells to
express the aromatase allowing for the
use of letrozole which is an aromatase
inhibitor and you can see that over time
the estrogen receptor expression level
this is looking at weeks post treatment
with lectures all and in a xenograph
model that over time that there's a
decrease in - surgeon receptor
expression but there's an increase in
her -
they then went on to do another study
where they use the mcf-7 aroma taste
expression expressing selves again in
his inna graph and they had a group that
they treated with less resolve and as
expected letters all initially caused
themselves or the tumors to not grow and
then after a certain amount of time the
tumour started to grow they had to set a
separate group of animals that when they
started saw that the tumor started to
grow they actually added trustees and a
bond and they thought decreasing growth
in those in those tumor so these results
suggest that in an estrogen receptor
model that we're actually starting to
see dependence upon the other pathway
against a nice sexy to depend on her to
or the EGFR pathway
sorry about that so what about tumors
that are her2 positive and you're
positive we have less data on those and
we are specifically interested in how er
or estrogen receptor is contributing to
growth in this in this context like I
mentioned earlier the cell the patients
that are treated with either of Roma
Tate's inhibitors or tamoxifen respond
differently whether whether her 2 is
present or not and so we're interested
to see what is er doing in the in this
context
so what I decided to do was model under
firm resistance and a her2 positive and
ER positive spell line
so there are challenges and modeling and
ERK and resistance the first is that
Mouse tumors do not are not dependent on
ER additionally that there are a few
cell lines that Express the R and that's
those that do sometimes Express but
don't actually again depend on ER and
media is critically important
so the first thing that's important
about media is that funeral read
contains an estrogenic contaminants and
so in the bottom left we're looking at
competitive binding affinity and you can
see that estradiol which is the first
line has a certain binding acidity in
mcf7 cells and then tamoxifen has a
slightly lower but still has a binding
affinity and you can see that phenol red
again still lower but it does have a
binding affinity and on the right side
they looked at cell number and saw that
with increasing concentrations of phenol
red that there was an increase in cell
growth suggesting that the big dis
contaminant when they added the phenol
read back into the media that there was
an increase in growth and our media
which is the IMM from get go is right
there on the scale so it is affected by
the phenol red contaminant that's
present
SPS which is fetal both fetal bovine
serum we also add to the media to help
the cells to grow field bovine serum or
FBS contains a lot of growth factors
that are not present in media but the
problem with FBS is that there's a
variability in hormone levels so this
graph is looking at different loss of
FBS and you can see across the eight
different lots that there are different
steroid hormone levels amongst them and
so if we're looking at how third
hormones are influencing the way that
the cells grow we need to make sure that
our levels are consistent across our
experiments and that they're not
confounded by having too high of levels
within the FBS
so to model there is a model
aromatisse what an aromatase inhibitor
would be doing to the cells we use a
process called long-term estrogen
deprivation so we take the cells that
are normally grown in 5% fps mmm
that contains the phenol red we switch
them to 5% CCS in a phenol red free meat
I am a mer medium
the problem with this is that the CCS or
the charcoal strip serum
which is sorry furniture matches on them
last night charcoal ships theorem Oh
stripped out a lot of the growth factors
and hormones that you have kind of a
baseline level of of growth of growth
factors
it also has reduced growth factors that
may work with that may signal through
her to through that EGFR through her
three through her four and so by
stripping we may be removing some of
those important growth factors for her
too and since we're interested in
focusing specifically on the role of
estrogen receptor we want to ensure that
we're not affecting the way that her to
is signaling and so I'm also developing
I CI resistant her or Sylvester and
resistance cell lines by taking the
cells that are normally grown in five
percent FBS with a phenol red containing
mmm and switching them to again still
means still containing the five percent
FBS we're using the five the phenol red
free IMM so removing that extra gentle
component and then we're adding
increasing doses of IC i-- or
cholesterin to reduce the amount of
estrogen receptor that's present within
the cell and this part of the my self
producing is under construction so I'm
not going to be talking about those
specifically I'm going to be talking
about the Ltd models
and so before I get into the health TV
models I want to give you a little bit
of background on our parental lines and
so we have three so liens that are her
two amplified and estrogen
receptor-positive and so you can see
from the Western blot below that all
three of the cell lines contain her2 and
estrogen receptor alpha this figure is
split into two parts I'm showing that on
the right with the red mmm that figure
will represent for the rest of the
presentation that the cells are in their
regular base media and on the left we
have the yellow looking flask which just
shows that the cells are strips and what
I do
so stripped is actually also a verb so
what I do this to strip the cells is I
remove the red media and put on clear or
yellow media and let that fit and then
change it daily for three days before
actually using the cells for an
experiment and that just tries to start
removing any of the residual hormone
that might be present within us within
that media and so
for my Ltd lines which I'll get into in
a minute I'm only focusing on the 360
months and the BT 474 is C 0 75 30s are
under construction still and one
important thing to know is that I'm
using two flasks I've developed two
flasks of each of these cell lines and
designated them LTE DEA and LTE DC if we
look at the normal growth within each of
these cell lines in response to some of
these therapies you can see that the BT
470 4s are more sensitive to TP or chest
tubes in that purchase a map so what I'm
showing you here is in the black bars
our control using the vehicle for each
of these different that the different
drugs are dissolved in a few different
concentrations of IC i-- or silvestra
that i added those are the pink bars and
then purple is TP alone two different
concentrations and then in the blue you
see the different combinations and so
again BTS are sensitive are more
sensitive to entrust you madam for twos
map whereas the 360 ones are resistant
to TP and respond well to IC I
so when you when making a long-term
estrogen the prize sells there are a few
ways to determine whether it's all to
actually become resistant so I'm not
increasing in concentrations of
something to show that a drug is getting
to that we're going to get to a certain
concentration those cells are going to
survive in that concentration we're just
removing the red component of the media
and so the two ways that I determine
resistance in my Ltd is to monitor the
regulation of estrogen regulated genes
in this case again I'm using that PG our
progesterone receptor and TF f1 which I
mentioned earlier and then I also
measure growth in response to estradiol
and I see I
so first we'll show you my results from
the gene expression
so what I did here was I took the bt
force of any fours and I put them
through the stripping and then treated
the cells with vehicle as my non-tree to
the control one animal or of estradiol
or ten animals of estradiol and you can
see that as expected that the
progesterone receptor and CF f1 both
increase in response to treatment of
estrogen
and when I look at the Ltd line so here
again the lighter colors represent
treatment with estradiol and red are the
Ltda and blue is Lt ADB and you can see
that there's an increase in the
constants are an increase in the
expression and PG progesterone receptor
and TFS one suggesting that there's not
any resistance that's occurring in these
cells so one thing I wanted to check
because all of these results are
normalized to their individual vehicle
so the parentals are normalized to their
vehicle the LCD is each or
individualized if it's normalized to
theirs as you can see by the bar for
vehicle being one across the board so I
wanted to compare the different vehicles
to see if there was any effect of
long-term estrogen deprivation on the
baseline gene expression and so you can
see that there was a slight decrease in
progesterone receptor expression but
that estrogen receptor esr1 is the gene
for estrogen receptor and TFS one didn't
really seem to have much effect if
anything PFF one went up a little bit so
then I looked at our 361 look it looked
up there see our target gene expression
and again you can see this beautiful
pattern where I see an increase with
increased concentrations there's
increased expression of the different
genes however in this case I did not see
any effect of of
on my Ltd line suggesting that these may
begin be starting to be resistant and
not dependent upon estrogen receptor
signaling and when I love to gannis
those baseline levels I thought I see
that not only is progesterone receptor
down its way down in comparison to the
BTS we also see now that GF f1 and us r1
or estrogen receptor gene expression so
as mRNA levels are decreased
so the next thing I wanted to do was to
measure growth in response to estradiol
and I VI
I took my parental cell lines and these
are in the base media and I looked at
those lighter to darker color or
increased concentrations of estrogen the
pink is with vehicle EtOH or ethanol and
then again increasing concentrations of
estrogen but with one micromolar
i see i and then finally I included TP
which is the one microgram per mil
trustees Navin produce map as kind of a
positive control for my BTS to show that
there was a decrease in growth so you
can see as expected in my parental lines
they're responding to both high CI and
then they have a further response
reduction of growth and response to TP
when I looked at my Ltd lines which
again are maintained in white media so
they're just they're plated and that as
well there's a slight reduction in the
effect of icy eye on growth but they
still are responding to icy eye with a
decrease in growth in earth as well as a
decrease in growth in response to TV
and when I looked at my 361 as expected
you know not really seeing I'm seeing a
large decrease in growth and response to
I see I and no response to TP and when I
looked at my lcd lines it looks like
they're responding less to I see eye
treatments and interestingly enough
we're starting to see that now there's a
decrease in respond and growth and
response to TP
so it looks like not only are my 361
cells let me go back for a second not
only are my 361 cells not responding as
such as well to to IC i-- or estradiol
they also are now decreasing in growth
in response to TP and so they seem to be
becoming a surgeon independent or
endocrine resistant but are they also
now responsive to TP
and so downstream targets are used to
determine chesty as metaphor cheese
madam efficacy remember from earlier
these two proteins for to when he FR
able to dimerize and then that
dimerization leads to phosphorylation of
a variety of proteins when I wish it's
bus pi3 kinase which causes the
phosphorylation of a KT so we can use
the phosphorylation of a KC as an
indicator that there's that the her2 or
EGFR is functioning so when we block
that we should using TP we should see a
decrease in phospho a KT and a decrease
in phospho EGFR because the pathway is
now inhibited
there's lots to look at the beauty for
74th in this case Bosco EGFR just before
I get started to orient you on the top I
have the parental and or the four nuts
parental line the next three are the Ltd
a and the next three are Ltd be
untreated treated with TPA or treated
with IC I and so you can see what's
possible EGFR as expected TP decreases
the amount of Faso EGFR that's present
in all three cell lines when we look at
phospho akt we see a similar pattern
so again TP is decreasing the amount of
phospho ATP's is present and then as
expected again when we treat with IC i
you see a reduction or a loss of
estrogen receptor because IC i is
estrogen receptors or greater but
estrogen receptors present and all three
cell lines
so when I looked at my 361 and phospho
EGFR I don't really see an effect in the
parentals as expected but I do see now
in my LTE DS that I'm decreasing the
amount of phosphorylation of EGFR the
response to TP I see a similar pattern
with phospho ET I think this was even
more beautiful and more pronounced so if
you look at the phoque so a 50 and the
parentals not only is that low B's
lowered basally we also don't see any
decrease in response to TP treatment
suggesting that they're resistant to
that but then when you look at the Ltd a
an Ltd be those bands are almost
completely gone in response to TB
treatment and again you're looking at
higher levels of kind of all these parts
of the signaling pathway for EGFR
signaling eg efforts the total EGFR is
up the total phospho and KT is up
and when we look at estrogen-receptor as
expected we see in the parentals that we
lose estrogen-receptor in response to a
CI and we also just lose a stratum earth
up there
so this corroborates our findings in the
gene expression where we see that
decrease in RNA in response to long term
estrogen deprivation and here we're
seeing again the protein level that
estrogen receptor is also decreased
so to summarize the cell models we see
that the BG 424 Ltd cells maintain
estrogen receptor and activity may also
mean seeing the TT response so there
doesn't seem to be a great effect of
long term estrogen deprivation on the
biology of the bt for semaphores the MM
360 ones which are going to resistance
to TP initially lose estrogen receptor
expression and activity and gain trust
these men produce map response the LTV
DS for the size 0 75 30s has been
largely unsuccessful but again I'm
continuing to try with those an IC is
resistant lines are developing so we can
get some answers to see through those IC
I resistant lines match what we see alt
ad or is there different phenotype
that's occurring when all of those
different growth factors are present but
in the absence of estrogen receptor so
our next steps for these cell lines are
to use these models to understand the
role of estrogen receptor in per to
positive and errant positive breast
cancer so what can these preclinical
results or to tell us about breast
cancer in the clinic so we went from
bedside to bench using some of those
clinical trials to determine and start
to look at some cell models what if we
how can we take this information to go
back to bedside so we currently use a
paradigm where we treat to failure so it
gives patients treatment until there's a
change so they get a treatment for an
extended period of time until there's a
chance to the change means that either
the cancer comes back or grows in some
cases it's an unfortunate side effect
you know there's a lot of different
reasons why we see failure but they're
treated to failure clinical trials
currently look at targeting both ER and
her to simultaneously which definitely
shows a promise but we're we're
proposing that we should potentially be
cycling treatments so kind of taking the
biology of the disease and showing that
you know that the cells in our culture
models at least are switching the
dependence on their pathway from
estrogen receptor to
the her2 pathway and back potentially
and so can we see should be recycling
treatments similarly in the clinic and
so at the bench I'm going to take those
Ltd cells the 360 ones that have become
estrogen and dependent and put them back
into the regular media or the media
containing phenol red free and SDS to
see what happens to the phenotypes there
and then take those cells and make them
resistant to trust use a map and per
tooth map so increasing you know ad
increasing concentrations with TP and
try to see if they regain their function
question involved in this is what
biomarkers should be used to determine a
switch so one of the things I showed you
was that a very drastic decrease in
phosphate ET that was not present in the
initial cell line but again these are
cells so what kind of other foods are
cells that represents tumors and so I
have a patient go through multiple your
biopsy is we have to think about what
biomarkers we can use to determine when
that's which is happening happening and
how to make that switch and our future
direction so our lab is moving forward
looking at four to positive or positive
breast cancer and we're trying to
determine specifically on the ear
dynamic and heterogeneity and see that
sweat see whether they're critical
drivers of this biology and then also
the response to her to targeted therapy
and with that I wanted to thank my lab
dr. Reagans has been a phenomenal mentor
and has really given me some scientific
freedom to start moving forward with
this project I have a vested interest in
her to positive breast cancer and so
it's been great to take my background of
hormones and move it towards you know
looking at a double positive situation
also all the people at Georgetown we
have some collaborators that are helping
us and of course always the patient
advocates it is so important to include
patient advocates when you're doing
research and asking questions about
science because they're the people who
will ultimately experience these
life-saving drugs that we're working
towards and with that I will take any
questions
Thank You dr. stires for your
informative presentation we will now
start the life you want a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for so let's get started
our first question is how do these two
different classes of receptor hurt to an
ER interact
um so I'm going to go back a few slides
to show you the kind of idiocy that that
hurt you and your pathways that overlap
so
in this case um
we see that estrogen receptor can
actually have non-ohmic effects and in
that kind of case we see phosphorylation
of estrogen receptor by some of these
downstream targets including HIV and
mass kinase which can phosphorylate the
estrogen receptor allowing for some of
those non-genomic effects and on the
opposite way when estrogen receptor
interacts in the nucleus and turns on
some of these turns on some of these
genes some of those genes include
pressure the receptor itself doesn't
cause her to or EGFR to because it
influence of protein levels of those but
it interacts with other co-regulators so
it can you know kind of influence it in
that way
now our next question why don't patients
adhere to treat so here is a problem
that's a lot of different diseases but
in breast cancer one of the big things
is side effect so like I mentioned in
the presentation patients will take the
drugs for ten to five to ten years and
in that time if you have a drug that's
giving you a side effect you're taking
it every single day
some patients will often not take it
specifically because of that additional
dosing schedules can be a little bit
challenging so you have to take it every
single day monitoring treatment so if
you're having you know to make sure that
patients are actually mom like actually
taking it you know it's kind of hard to
determine what their patients are or not
the treatment cost is a big thing so
their insurance isn't covering it or
even if their insurance is but there's a
high copay that can kind of deter
patients from actually taking the drug
desires wife phenol read in media in the
first place Sophie no Loretta is
actually indicator of pH so we include
in all red because cells and they're
going to respiration and kind of you
know growing on a dish we see changes in
pH and those changes can be detrimental
to the cells growth and survival so we
include phenol red as a way to measure
and it turns yellow and the cells become
acidic or the media and that the cells
are living and become acidic and so we
include fetal reless red as that
indicator and do cells express both
estrogen receptor and her two at the
same time so this is one thing that
we're working on actively in the lab
actually we are interested to see
whether this expression is you know so
happening simultaneously or their cells
within the population that some of them
express her to and some of them
expressed estrogen receptor and then
similarly we also want to it in the near
future look at tumors that we have a
tumor microarray or DNA that we're using
to love to see within a tumor if we have
a patient who their tumor has expresses
both estrogen and receptor and her to
whether they're in the same cells and we
can use that we can do that using
fluorescence so we can actually stay in
for both at the same time and that will
allow us to determine whether it's
expressed in both and we want to move
forward kind of depending on what answer
that tells us that kind of will help
Weston for what might be happening with
the biology with the disease
desires it looks like we do have time
for one more question so we'll end with
this one does resistance occur with the
use of per to targeted therapies
so unfortunately it does it is at a
lower rate of what we can tell so far
wave so one thing I didn't mention I
talked a lot about the use of Trustees
map and Purdue's map or Herceptin and
pajetta
and a study within the past few years
actually showed that the addition of
Purdue's map to trusted map alone
improved survival and so in that case
we've actually started using gender
disparities both therapies at once so a
lot of our studies looking at resistance
look specifically at the use of only
trust use map or Herceptin alone and 15
to 24 percent of patients you have a
recurrence or a recurrence and that
media the records happens within 8 to 11
years so that's like the percentage of
patients that have a current at that
time these drugs have only been around
the 90s so we don't have as much data as
we do on the estrogen targeted therapies
but unfortunately does seem to also
happen there
Thank You dr. stires do you have any
final comments for our audience
I don't think I do thank you all for
listening I really appreciate everyone
being here and feel free to tweet at me
if you have questions I will post the
article that got this figure of the her2
and here our target pathways I'll treat
that out so the people who are
interested in looking to see I also have
a publication about adherence I I'll
tweet that up too so follow me along and
Twitter
thank you again dr. stires for your time
today Andrew important research we would
also like to thank laberd's and our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting question questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through June of
2019 Labyrinth will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues miss miss today's live
event until next time goodbye